what uh
computing hardware
or um just any kind of even software
design are you
uh do you find beautiful from your own
work from
other people's work the year just uh we
were just talking about the
the battleground of flaws and mistakes
and errors but
things that were just beautifully done
is there something that pops to mind
when things are beautifully done usually
there's a well thought out set of
abstraction layers
so the whole thing works in unison
nicely yes
and and when i say abstraction layer
that means two different components when
they work together
they work independently they don't have
to know what the other one is doing
so that decoupling yeah so the famous
one was the the network stack like
there's a seven-layer network stack you
know data transport and protocol and
all the layers and the innovation was is
when they really wrote got that right
because networks before that didn't
define those very well
the layers could innovate independently
and occasionally the layer boundary
would would you know the interface would
be upgraded
and that that let you know the the
design space breathe
and you could do something new in layer
seven without having to worry about how
layer four worked
right and so good design does that and
you see it in processor designs
when we did the zen design at amd
we made several components very modular
and you know my insistence at the top
was i wanted all the interfaces to find
before we wrote the rtl for the pieces
one of the verification leads said if we
do this right i can test the pieces
so well independently when we put it
together we won't find all these
interaction bugs because the floating
point knows how the cache
works and i was a little skeptical but
he was mostly right
that the modularity of design greatly
improved the quality
is that universally true in general
would you say about good designs the
modularity
is like usually we talked about this
before humans are only so smart like
and we're not getting any smarter right
but the complexity of things is going up
yeah so you know a beautiful design
can't be bigger than the person doing it
it's just you know their piece of it
like the odds of you doing a really
beautiful design of something that's way
too hard for you is low
right if it's way too simple for you
it's not that interesting
it's like well anybody could do that but
when you get the right match of
your your expertise and you know mental
power
to the right design size that's cool but
that's not big enough to make a
meaningful impact in the world
so now you have to have some framework
to design the
pieces so that the whole thing is big
and harmonious
but you know when you put it together
it's you know sufficiently sufficiently
interesting
to be used and you know so that's like a
beautiful design is
you